[Musique]
en père est exactement comme n'importe
quel homme d'affaires il est comme tous
les gens responsables de vies humaines
vous comprenez si je pouvais avoir le
rôle dans le film ça me relancerai ce
serait bien
deux producteurs de lait ou tu prendras
paulo j'ai aucune chance je vais lui
faire une offre qui ne pourra pas
refuser
vous savez que mon père tu as franchi le
site moi qui voulais pas tromper les
mains dans le business
[Musique]
je croyais que tu ne voulais pas devenir
comme ton père
[Musique]
j'ai jamais voulu que ça pour toi
dumont grand frère et je t'aime moment
et ne prend jamais partie contre la
famille avec x ou 20 ans jamais
michael francis reid ci renonce tu as à
temps j'y renonce
11 pas de questions sur mes chauffeurs
est ce que c'est vrai
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
laisse le flag
prend les cannellonis
[Musique]
à
on